oh hi
oh sorry I'm just very aware of how
close you are to my bomb
is this a game I don't know about oh
this is planking no no no I'm hiding for
a net are you like more like an extra
weight
[Music]
hey ru Jun yeah
Tiffany wants you to have your stuff
back she she couldn't face me herself
she's busy
you
[Music]
Tiffany travel mug her pen her here - oh
this is mine hey Tiffany
kid you this is my new roommate Lily hey
what's up new roommate
oh and Lili I like to party and have fun
all the time
you're gonna get sick of her
[Music]
Wow she really that good her money no
but you know nobody likes change
oh hey June hey didn't he oh this is her
cheated genes new roommate oh really
yeah
she's loads of fun I have us but
laughing since I moved in yeah hey
pepper
well his roommate stay out right Jun
must go yeah nice to meet you Teresa
but it's Tiffany oh my God thank you so
much
honestly don't mention it you don't even
know how much you helped me oh [ __ ] I'm
like this white clothes
they're so lovely running into you I'll
see you around
oh [ __ ]